la guerre a commencé il ya soixante et
onze jours elle n'est pas prête de
s'arrêter mais déjà les européens
pensent à l'avenir et à la
reconstruction ils organisent une
conférence de donateurs en présence
virtuelle du président hélène skip 500
milliards d'euros par an seraient
nécessaires selon les estimations la
france annonce une nouvelle enveloppe
écouter emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui je souhaite vous annoncer
que la france portera son appui global à
2 milliards de dollars afin de répondre
aux besoins exprimés par le président
ukrainien la france continuera à agir de
manière concertée dans le cadre de
l'union européenne avec nos partenaires
européens dans le cadre aussi du g7 et
des institutions financières
internationales afin d'être
collectivement à la hauteur des besoins
de l'état ukrainien face à la
catastrophe de cette guerre
j'ajoute que nous devons nous organiser
et être prêts à assumer cet effort dans
la durée dans le contexte d'un conflit
qui malheureusement risque de se
poursuivre et dont nous n'avons pas
encore vu toutes les conséquences
dramatiques